こんにちははじめしたちょっと先取締役です
今日は
非常に真面目の話があります
本当にはライン出しで
聞いてほしいと思っております実は私肇社長ですね
大学も卒業して社会人になって大学時代は大学に行くことが多かったので
大学に来るまとめると思えないしバイクでいいかなと思ってずっとバイクに乗ってた
わけなんですけども
あの子ツアー
ちょっと前に車を購入いたしまして
愛告白集することですねねいやー後真っ先にもね
のセット b 一緒にどっか出かけたでした動画で何かものが必要になっている
すぐものを運べてたまーに東京にで車でこういったいってすごい快適で抹茶こそ次も
押し出して社会人としてね
車が合ってるいいかなと思って関係ってただけなんですけども
ふざけるところですねまずままずは本当の本当の話をさせて頂きますと
その車のマフラーが開基ガスが出る車のマフラーという部分があるんですけども
盗まれておりました
南米なんで粘れローズ踏まれるだろうなと思ったけどさ
盗まれたユ竜がされるだろうなと思って言わなかったけどさ
言わなくてもされると思うどうすればいいの
本当に何本当に立ちある人がいるなって思いますよ僕はこっちの犯罪立の普通に盗んだ
奴らお前ら見てるかまずの犯罪だからな
悪いけど警察に言いに行きますから本当に
思っています
どぉすればいい
1回も動画が言ってないし乗っているところも外で見られただよねってば降らなくなっ
てるんだよ
あどっかやっぱり立てるは色じゃないドリームズない本当にやばいと本当に深刻な問題
です
なんでさんの車が何かっていうこともような様がいいなと思って今まで行って来なかっ
たんですけども
三角は普通に犯罪ですのでもし盗んだ人を
ん
この動画を見ていると僕のマフラーを返してください
非常にかっこ悪いですよなぜらは高いスレでも
のマフラーだけ交換書く買う人にいないぐらいからねさっきまで落ち込んでなんか今
まで出会った人たちの歴史子みたいなのはずっとビジョンした皆さんてどうすれば良い
と思いますこういう宿に聞きたいよね持ってたら盗撮されそうだした
持ってなくても盗撮されですもうホント迷惑なんで出来れば
盗みは止めちゃく数ですできればそうだけど
上でやめてほしいですねよってゆけで賭博が娘たちといったら
正直に言っていただいで返してくれるとありがたいです
感じで車を問題をどうするかで今後もう一度
同曲についていると a nurse てほしいですよね
例えばね車持ってる男の人が言うとその人の車のパーツが取られて男の人はどうぼうか
ブーブー言って受けますクールマティどうぞあー結構多いやすくにょたら喋っ
低動画だと思われてますけど普通に大犯罪が起こったんだよね本当にね
悪いことは悪いです
ダメなことはダメですマフラーなバーンねー
でてこいやー
あっ始めるよねっ
me
あっ